les dijonnais profitant des plaisirs
déborde louche
une image qui appartient au cycle
dernier l'institut national de
recherches archéologiques préventives
exhume se passer sur un parking de
l'ancien hôpital général ici 60 mètres
de quais sont apparus certains fondée au
xviie siècle sous louis xiv d'autres
construction remonte au 19e tous ces
vestiges témoignent de la grande
frénésie qui régnait dans ce quartier à
un jet de pierre du coeur de la ville
imaginez plutôt sur le pavé les
aubergistes côtoyer les lavandières
les dijonnais en goguette croiser les
grossistes en place et on sait que
depuis le moyen âge le faubourg raines
occupés par des poissonniers on sait
qu'en 18e à une personne dont j'ai
oublié le nom ici avait 23 vivier des
fosses à poissons et donc cet ensemble
de cases qui est au contact de l'eau en
permanence donc aidé interprétés comme
étant des viviers outre ces éléments de
pisciculture qui ont surpris les
archéologues même c'est une myriade
d'objets qui a été mis au jour
tesson vaisselle pot de moutarde
médaille de pèlerin et encore les
scientifiques n'ont fouillé que la
première strate d'histoire d'ici la fin
de l'année il prévoit de s'enfoncer un
peu plus dans le sol et dans le temps
direction le moyen-âge
on espère trouver des vestiges en bois
conserver puisque on sort d'un milieu
plutôt vaseux donc un milieu à nairobi
sans oxygène ce qui fait que les
éléments ne en fait ne dispense pas donc
on peut trouver du tissu on peut trouver
du bois on peut trouver des nas voilà
donc c'est bon évidemment c'est pour
l'instant un espoir mais en fait il ya
un potentiel important dans cette
deuxième phase des poules
l'objectif de ces fouilles et de faire
progresser les connaissances
scientifiques
la topographie des quais sera
scrupuleusement relever les vestiges
minutieusement étudiées et ensuite me
direz vous et bien ensuite ses berges
louche seront à nouveau remblayer comme
dans les années 60 pour laisser place à
la construction de la cité de la
gastronomie ce lieu vivra alors une
nouvelle page de son histoire